llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en france24 y para eso está conmigo luis
méndez luis bienvenido y comencemos en
eeuu porque la reserva federal la fed y
anunció un aumento en las tasas de
interés de qué se trata acidez me
declara fue un aumento de un cuarto de
punto porcentual para ubicarse en el
rango entre 0 25 y
0.5 por ciento y es la primera vez que
se incrementan desde el año 2018 de
acuerdo con gran pago el presidente de
este organismo la intención es controlar
la presión sobre los precios en su
intento por mantener o controlar la
inflación que ha registrado su máximo
nivel en los últimos o de los últimos 40
años y que de acuerdo con la reserva
federal podría seguir su aumento para el
afecta la alta inflación es una
consecuencia de los tests equilibrados e
incrementos de oferta y demanda y
tiestos guardan relación con la pandemia
los precios elevados de la energía y los
problemas en la cadena de suministro a
pesar de la situación la fed desea
responder al mandato gubernamental
permitir la recuperación económica de la
pandemia pero por otro lado el
presidente de la reserva federal anunció
una revisión a la baja de la tasa de
crecimiento para este año y la redujo a
2.8 por ciento desde un 4 por ciento que
fue presentado en diciembre de 2021
escuchemos
estamos viendo precios más altos del
petróleo de las materias primas y
creemos que eso influirá en el pib hasta
cierto punto eso es parte de lo que
movió esas evaluaciones a la baja pero
recuerden ese 2,8 por ciento es un
fuerte crecimiento económico
es otra de las noticias económicas es
que aumenta la expectativa por la
posibilidad de impago de rusia algo que
no se ve desde 1917 es posibles es
posible ya lo habían anunciado distintos
organismos porque este miércoles se
cumplió el lapso para que la federación
rusa para que 117 puntos 2 millones de
dólares de intereses en bonos recibidos
por lo que ya comenzó a regir un período
de gracia de 30 días para que la nación
pueda cumplir con estas obligaciones
días el fondo monetario internacional-
había señalado que el incumplimiento de
pago por parte de rusia no parecía un
evento improbable la nación de acuerdo
con medios como la razón de españa' hizo
frente a su compromiso pero en rublos
algo que los analistas consideran que es
un default puesto que los compromisos
deben ahorrarse en moneda extranjera en
este caso en dólares pero aunque el
departamento del tesoro estadounidense
ha señalado que las sanciones impuestas
producto de la invasión rusa a ucrania
no afectan su condición para pagar lo
cierto es que el gobierno se ha escudado
en éstas y dejó la pelota en el
territorio de las naciones occidentales
porque lo anunció el ministro de finanza
que la posibilidad o imposibilidad de
cumplir las obligaciones no depende de
rusia así lo indicó el representante del
gobierno en una entrevista al medio
tape pero las sanciones han golpeado la
economía rusa en los últimos días y el
gobierno hace esfuerzos por resistir
pese a que indicadores como la inflación
se ubican en el orden del 12.5 por
ciento por escuchemos que dijo el
presidente vladimir putin sobre la
situación
de la nueva realidad de requerirán
profundos cambios estructurales en
nuestra economía y no ocultaré no serán
fáciles conducirán a un aumento temporal
de la inflación y el desempleo nuestra
tarea en esta situación es minimizar
riesgos más tributos ni productos el
propósito de las sanciones que usted nos
estaba hablando occidente anuncia una
mayor presión de qué se trata es que un
día después que la unión europea diera a
conocer que a habrán más sanciones y
éstas serían más duras en contra de
rusia el gobierno de suiza informó que
establecido sanciones para ver la luz
que entre otras cosas incluye la
prohibición de prestación de asistencia
técnica y la importación de madera
caucho y cemento de ese país las medidas
fueron tomadas por el respaldo de esta
nación a rusia en su invasión ucrania
asimismo se conoció que la empresa
qualcomm dejará de suministrar productos
a compañías rusas y de acuerdo con
informaciones de agencias rusas que se
citan en declaración de jens a que eeuu
estaría evaluando una mayor presión pero
debido a que muchas naciones europeas
dependen en gran parte de las
exportaciones rusas específicamente del
mercado energético francia anunció un
plan de 28 mil millones de euros que
estará destinado a empresas y hogares
que se han visto afectados por el
aumento de la energía louis y muy
brevemente cuáles son los indicadores en
eeuu cierres positivos en este caso por
los números o la información de la
reserva federal también nuevos números
positivos en el mercado europeo y al
asiático también hubo cierres positivos
en américa latina graciasluis y a
ustedes los invitamos a que sigan
conectados con france24
[Música]
ah